So now we've arrived at these two equations. This is what we learned about Euler's number,
and this is what you saw in the previous quiz about the exponential function.
Where X was equal to pi. These equations are very elegant, but highly inefficient.
Who wants to compute the product of millions or billions of factors?
Power series come to our rescue. If you actually want to compute Euler's number or the exponential function,
you're going to use power series. So let's try and turn this product into a sum of powers of X.
To get started, here's a quiz for you: One plus X over four to the fourth power. What would that be?
Some number without X plus some number times X, plus some number times X squared,
plus some number times X to the third power, plus some number times X to the fourth power.
Fill in these numbers using integers such as three or fractions such as five over 42.